[Music]
this is IOT 205 which is about growing
the IOT with LP Wayne and Laura my name
is Calvin Barnes I'm a product manager
on cloud IOT core and I also focus on
working with low-power networking
technologies for Google I have with me a
team that I'll let introduce themselves
as well my name is Vivek Mohan I'm the
director of marketing for Laura products
at septic and Victor amo product manager
at obscene use alright awesome thanks
guys this is hopefully gonna be both
exciting and educational today to talk
about LP wayne technologies and Laura
both of genius and SEM tech our founders
of Laura alliance and leaders in the
space we will have time for questions at
the end but given the format that we're
in here if you have questions throughout
I think it's good to have a discussion
we're each gonna be talking about
different areas so feel free to put your
hands up or come up to the microphone
here the presenters have told me they
prefer that so that they can actually
hear you on the recording but feel free
to ask questions or let us know if
there's things you want us to clarify
when it comes to IOT connectivity
options so if you've been to the other
IOT sessions at next in the previous two
days you've probably seen this slide a
lot but we're connecting more things to
the Internet than ever before but
actually what this session is about is
about those things that haven't been
connected to the Internet yet for one
reason or another they struggle with
existing connectivity options and
there's generally a few reasons that
products or companies struggle when
they're trying to connect things to the
Internet and it comes down to power cost
and range or some combination of the
three so first of all power there are a
lot of devices that don't have mains
power or can't be recharged frequently
and that makes it hard in some cases to
actually get the connectivity to them
that they need especially if they need
to
cast long ranges over wireless next is
cost and this comes down to module cost
as well as recurring costs that it takes
to actually connect devices to the
Internet and this is especially a
problem for devices or applications
where you need to connect a huge number
of devices in order to get significant
ROI on whatever your use case is even as
module costs come down and connectivity
costs come down there are still use
cases that need it to be cheaper needs
to be smaller need to be more power
efficient and finally range which
generally comes into account on
compounding these two so we have pretty
good low power options today we have
pretty good connectivity infrastructure
that you can connect to for pretty cheap
but if you need your devices to connect
over very long ranges or in lots of
situations then this can also be a big
challenge so let's talk about some of
the use cases that this is a challenge
for one that I think is very interesting
and as applicable to LP one is metering
and smart metering so this has been a
problem that smart cities and energy
companies have wanted to solve for a
long time where instead of sending
somebody around to each energy meter to
read it they want it to be able to
report automatically all the time but
there are challenges here because the
energy company typically doesn't control
the connectivity which is you know near
the meter generally energy meters are in
weird locations in buildings and
honestly it's pretty cheap to send
somebody around and read each meter
individually so in order to get good ROI
reading them has to be radically cheaper
next is agriculture so agriculture
whether it's livestock or farming has
challenges in connectivity because you
have big open spaces and in some cases
you have lots of assets so you don't
can't put a cellphone on every single
cow that you have to track its location
and if you have large open fields you
might need lots of environmental sensors
in areas where there isn't even good
cellular connectivity let alone mains
power to keep them going
and finally one that Victor is going to
talk to you more about later is asset
tracking and I think this is a really
good example of why lp1 is gonna help
grow the IOT because things like asset
tracking and fleet management are not
new IOT use cases there's lots of
companies out there doing this today but
given the cost of connectivity whether
it's you know keeping the devices
Cellular connected or having to recharge
the batteries all the time it's kept
asset tracking only two pretty
high-value assets so companies still
have a hard time tracking everything
through the entire supply chain so
before we start talking about new
solutions and how they can help these
industries let's look a little bit about
how things work today you have three
major options for connectivity with IOT
today and I promise you probably know
about these if you're here at this
session listening to this but it'll be
important for framing things later you
have personal area network so these are
things like Bluetooth ZigBee thread and
they're great for short-range
communication and they already are quite
power efficient there's lots of exciting
things happening in this space today
then you have local area networks this
is what a lot of IOT devices choose to
use things like Wi-Fi and Ethernet
we have great existing infrastructure
for it almost everybody has Wi-Fi in
their house it works most of the time
unless you're here at a conference like
this then maybe it works but even with
advances in costs we still have mediocre
battery life on Wi-Fi and Ethernet
devices and finally you have traditional
cellular options which give great range
great coverage and the networks are
already deployed in most places but both
the cost of the modules and the
recurring cost of paying for cellular
data can be quite expensive especially
if you're trying to connect millions of
assets for whatever your project is so
now let's talk about how lp1 which is a
technology that's really bit a set of
technologies which have really been
driven by the needs of IOT customers and
IOT use cases are starting to change
this so l Pym technologies can give you
much better battery life than cellular
and Wi-Fi they can give you
arranged in personal area networks and
can be cheaper than traditional cellular
but it does come at a cost of much much
lower bandwidth but for IOT applications
this is actually generally not a problem
being able to sacrifice bandwidth
because you only need to send a few
bytes of sensor data a day actually
makes a lot of sense if you can connect
these devices super cheaply have them
run on about a single battery for years
at a time while communicating to base
stations that are miles or killed miles
away so let's see how lp1 stacks up to
our existing connectivity options in the
few key areas that we talked about
causing problems for IOT connectivity
today so in terms of range in bandwidth
you have personal area networks that are
sort of low on both and then you have
cellular networks that give great
bandwidth in great range today lp1 is
some somewhere down here on the bottom
where you have very very low bandwidth
in some cases only bytes per day but you
actually have as good if not maybe a
little bit better range with some lq and
technologies than traditional cellular
now let's look at cost you have pretty
much the existing infrastructure and the
pam technologies are very very low cost
today both in terms of module and
overall pricing and then you have
cellular which give great range but not
only the module is more expensive but
you have to pay a cellular provider
every single month and even with new IOT
pricing plans it can be quite expensive
if you need to connect large numbers of
devices and this is where lp1 is really
going to help companies bring down the
cost because you have again just as good
a range as cellular but in many cases
much lower costs and that's driven by
the size of the payloads but it's also
driven by the fact that if you want to
you can deploy lp1 yourself and then you
don't have any network provider that
you're paying every month every year now
let's talk about power usage or
ultimately how long you're going to get
on battery
and I think this is where it really
shines through how great lp1 is you have
your traditional pan technologies like
Bluetooth thread ZigBee the 15-4
technologies down here where we have
very very low power usage but very very
low range and then you have in the
opposite corner a traditional set of our
LP when we're hoping is going to change
this because we can get almost as good a
battery life as we do with the personal
area network technologies and almost as
long a range as with traditional
cellular so this set of technologies is
pretty exciting going forward for
helping drive more adoption in the IOT
so let's talk about some of the options
and I'm gonna let the other guys get up
here because they're the experts but you
have sig Fox which is a single vendor
but multinational network where you can
go to them and buy one radio that will
work in multiple places you have Laura
which is driven by the Laura Alliance an
open network technology that has network
providers which support it in many
places in the world today and then you
have NB IOT which is a standard from
3gpp it's the same standards group that
does the 3G and 4G standards and
typically these are networks that are
deployed by traditional telecom
companies today we really want to focus
on talking about Laura and telling you
more about that so without further ado
have the vet come up and talked about it
thanks kiddo
so we're gonna touch on a lot of
Technology and then Victor talked about
how it's used in an actual use case so
as we start you know Simtek for those of
you that are not familiar with the
company we are a semiconductor company
we've been around for 60 years designing
analog mixed signal ICS and about five
years ago we saw customers trying to
solve a problem right there's many use
cases that you can see up here in the
smart city segment in supply chain and
logistics in smart buildings where you
have these sensors that don't have
access to line power there may be
monitoring you know leaks in a pipe in
your basement they may be an elevator
shaft detecting vibration or there may
be a water meter or a gas meter that's
very deep on the ground and these don't
send a lot of data to the network right
so they may send a few times a day small
payloads they need to have really long
range and existing technologies don't
offer the power consumption and the cost
benefits right so if you look at Wi-Fi
or Bluetooth you really need to add in a
lot of repeaters or you need a mesh
network like ZigBee where it adds cost
of infrastructure so if you look at the
carpet our capex and OPEX it doesn't
work so we brought a lot of technology
to the market with the goal of providing
long-range connectivity at a fraction of
the cost and fraction of power
consumption of existing technologies so
what is Laura right there's
fundamentally two ways people send data
out of these sensor networks you know if
you've attended any of the IOT sessions
at this conference a lot of talk is
about edge computing with the HTTP you
announcement cloud computing all of this
needs data but the problem that
enterprises and businesses are trying to
solve is how do you extract data from
these things that could be located
anywhere right that's a hard problem to
solve and that's where simpler comes in
so if you look at the the figure here
you can see that you can either optimize
for frequency spectrum so if you're
using licensed spectrum like NB IOT or
else
traditionally the entire network is
architected to be optimized around
spectrum efficiency right that's what
that's their main driver because it's
expensive with Laura it operates an
unlicensed spectrum and we use something
called spread spectrum which is
beneficial because we live in a very
noisy RF environment right there's Wi-Fi
there's Bluetooth there's all sorts of
things constantly transmitting around us
so you need to have a technology that
can transmit be robust in the presence
of interferers and we use spread
spectrum which allows the receiver to
actually recover the signal even if it's
below the noise level it's low power and
it's low complexity so if you're to
scale LP van and IOT to the millions and
billions that analysts are predicting
the cost has to be extremely low at the
sensor side which means we don't add a
lot of processing complexity or
processing capability all the way of
these sensors for these types of
applications so we focused on building
Laura and Laura Wan on low power and to
keep the end nodes and the hardware
costs really low it's bi-directional
with adaptive data rates so if you can
think about it if you have a gateway and
you have a sensor that's maybe closer to
the Gateway it doesn't mean to blast out
its packet at full power right you can
back off the power and all of that is
network controlled with something called
adaptive data rate so you can trade off
the data rate for range and optimize
power consumption on the sensor side
it's tolerant to moving objects so for
asset management which you know Victor
will show you an example of how Laura
van is used in asset tracking you can
still use this mentioned robust to
interference and one of the key features
related to asset management is GPS free
geolocation so you can do this if you
have an application or a use case that
requires anywhere from maybe 50 meters
in a rural environment to a hundred and
fifty meters in an urban environment
we're not talking about sub meter
accuracy right but there's plenty of
applications you may need to do
geofencing or C if you know a car in
your fleet has has left a certain area
things like that
so there's many use cases where GPS as
we all know is extremely power hungry
and it obviously adds cost to the sensor
as well so we figured out a way using
our time difference of arrival do know
where the sensor is without adding
additional cost on the sensor itself so
it provides good location for outdoor
applications without battery impact in
the sense that there is no GPS trying to
acquire satellites in a position fix
constantly it's bi-directional so if you
want to do firmware updates over-the-air
now in these applications because these
sensors may be in places that are very
difficult to access but they still need
to last 5 10 15 even 20 years in some
cases in the field over-the-air updates
are important you can have
acknowledgments come back from the
network indicating that the networks
received a packet and also for key
exchange right you can activate sensors
over-the-air so you need bi-directional
communication Laura Wan is driven by the
laura alliance it's an industrial liens
of over 500 companies and laura Wan is
the Mac layer protocol and the aim of
this is to standardize and open-source
the mac layer protocol so that you have
interoperability amongst all these
sensors and we can kind of define some
standards around it which is a real way
to scale all these networks
it's got global support and it also
supports roaming across networks and
security is really important you know
these n nodes they may have a secure
element in some cases to store the keys
so security and provisioning is also
thought of all the way from the sensor
to the cloud and different layers in
between so what does the architecture
look like right so you've got a bunch of
sensors transmitting data and most of
these are uplink to the gateways the way
this is architected it's a star topology
and any gateway within range of a sensor
will be able to receive the packet right
so typically in an installation you'll
have more than one gateway that can that
a sensor can hit
so these sensors send packets up to the
gateway the gateways are pretty simple
packet followers is not a huge amount of
processing complexity again with the aim
of offloading all of that processing to
places where you have the capability to
do that and the resources to do that so
we want to keep the cost of these
gateways not only of the sensors but
also the gateway is really low right and
then you've got you know the network
server and the application server which
could reside in the cloud or may be
on-premise in some applications if you
if you have other concerns so one thing
that's important to note is you know
kilo mention SiC Fox and NV IOT and
Laura's options right and when we think
about wide area networks we typically
think of the mobile network operators in
the case of Laura and you can actually
build private networks as well because
the cost of the infrastructure and the
simplicity of the protocol allow you to
do that so if you've got a specific area
to cover and you want to do that and you
can afford the infrastructure you can go
ahead and do that and still be lot of
Wang compliant and build your network
that way so there's multiple options in
terms of deployment strategies can be
private can be public it can be a hybrid
mix of both so I'll talk about the the
Laura Lyons I mentioned that you know
it's the industrial lines that's
defining the Laura one standard it's an
openly available specification so you
can access it from the laura alliance
website it's a large ecosystem from
silicon providers like sem tech to
solutions and everything in between it's
got a global certification program to
ensure a certain minimum level of
quality of sensors and it defines
end-to-end security so one thing to
point out here is Laura Wan is really
focused on the Mac right the physical
layer the radio itself is Laura and
that's a modulation that's spread
spectrum modulation the Mac layer is
where you have multiple options so
you've got three different classes in
Laura one which trade-off latency for
power consumption so in class a if you
have a sensor that will send data only
when it
it's - and there's no Network initiated
traffic then that's your class a mode
which is optimized for the lowest lowest
power consumption but the latency is
higher because your network can actually
initiate a communication with the sensor
then you've got Class B which is similar
to a beaconing system where the network
sends out periodic beacons and the
sensors listen to that and they wake up
at those intervals kind of similar to
Wi-Fi beacons if you want to think about
it that way which you know has maybe a
little bit higher power consumption than
Class A mode but still is a good balance
between latency and power consumption
and then you've got Class C where the
sensors are constantly receiving right
this could be an application like a
streetlight we've got a lot of wind
deployments that are going into
streetlights and smart cities and these
streetlights always have line power so
power consumption is not a huge concern
for these street lights so they're
always receiving the other way Class C
is used is if you want to do firmware
updates over-the-air right we all know
that Laura Wan is a low bandwidth low
data rate system so updating firmware
could take you know a few minutes maybe
half an hour depending on you know how
much data you want to send so one of the
ways it's implemented is you could
actually switch a sensor to Class C mode
get your updates done quickly and then
switch it back to Class A right so
there's different ways of implementing
it and still optimizing for power
consumption so if you want additional
information semtex hosts something
called a lot of community it's a website
where we list products services from
ecosystem partners you can collaborate
with others that have adopted Laura
technology there's about 50 million
sensors today that are actually deployed
so the technology itself I think is
quite proven you can get support from
our technical experts in the community
and get a lot of good resources in terms
of application notes and use cases and
finally the Laura wine Academy so one
interesting thing we started seeing was
a lot of university professors were
interested in IOT courses
and experimenting with IOT and teaching
the next generation of engineers so
together with partners we've created a
Laura wine Academy which essentially
gives universities
Laura wine gateway and a few sensors and
it's got a full curriculum that's all
online so it's provided as courses in
different universities we've got about
10 universities signed up right now and
it's a full package that professors can
use to teach courses they can use it for
research into the lp wine space and
prepare really everybody for real-world
IOT right so for additional information
on that you know you can check out the
Laura one academy website with that said
I'm going to hand it back to to Caleb
[Applause]
thanks Vic before I let Victor come up
here and talk about network operators
and some really use cases just wanted to
talk a little bit about how Google cloud
has recently joined the Laura alliance
and what this means for IOT and from
Google's perspective think it's a clear
signal that we think standards and open
alliances will play a huge role in
adoption of IOT and IOT connectivity and
Laura alliances goals around
interoperability and open standards I
think really aligned with Google clouds
mission of trying to build the most open
cloud that there is a lot of what we're
gonna do with Google cloud is we think
that the infrastructure that we have in
the global network that Google has built
and is available to our customers
through Google cloud will be great for
network operators these are going to be
everything from independent companies to
telecom companies that will deploy Laura
base stations and offer Laura networks
to end-users and secondly we think it
will be great for the customers for the
use cases that I talked about before
because we are going to work with these
network operators to build integrations
from their networks into Google cloud so
that companies that are using Laura as a
connectivity base layer for their
applications will be able to leverage
the data analytics machine learning and
other tools available to them inside
Google cloud and to tell you a little
bit more about companies that are doing
that for real I'm gonna have Victor from
of genius come up and tell you more
thank you
ok so I'm very glad to be here with you
and to share what is of genuine what we
do as a network operator and we state it
with a specific use case about asset
tracking so option use of genius is a
subsidiary of boot tracker which part of
a big group which is a huge worldwide
cooperation in various sector present in
various sectors like telecommunication
construction and TV
objects is dedicated to internet of
sinks and as a company has been in the
business on the French market for almost
two years
some would says that we are a visible
part of the iceberg of the iceberg
because we act like the startup and we
have a powerful group behind us objects
has deployed a national level one
network thanks to the help of victory
come and we are the first national
network dedicated to Internet of Things
in France thanks to a 400
4,300 gateway all over France like that
we cover more than 95% of the population
and 86% of the territory the last part
is the fact that network is entirely
super-sized and maintained by the boot
telecoms teams which also on the other
networks such as 4G - to understand what
we do we are divided the IOT in five
layers the first concerned devices which
we don't manufacture in fact we will I
on the very rich ecosystem from the
lower alliant of device maker and
solution maker to reference them and
make them available for our customers
the second one is network and security
as a network as network provider we we
offer services with some guarantee for
customers in particular in terms of
security because it can be a major issue
for them when successor when the sensor
are connected to a network they will be
able to send messages and it can be
exploited in spot our product and I will
explain in the next slide in the next
slide and we have a range of feature
from device management to data
visualization so as it will correspond
to the third and the first layer and
finally the last layer
business intelligence
which will correspond to end-to-end
solution on specific vertical and we are
not addressing that directly we are in
fact with partners we are specialized
and expand on it we give this this last
this last break here a screen shot from
a platform spot
it's a transverse on a Liam taggable IOT
platform and which we've API and
connector this platform is entirely
customizable and and trulia adapt to the
need of our customer with the features a
desire we can separate the feature into
two parts the first one is a set of
tools to manage your fleet of objects in
complete autonomy from the connection to
the management of all kind of objects it
in 3d it including the technical
supervision and the device management
the group and user modeling and also the
motoring monitoring of the connectivity
and it's also possible to analyze
visualize and supervise your activity
thanks to a complete suit of
visualization and that analysis tool
like that we can create some dashboard
and we have some option with data
decoding alerting and you're tracking
that I will show you in the in the use
case just after a quick overview of
architecture of the spot system so on
the Left we have the lower network
server that will manage the flow between
the object on the network it will
configure us a bit rate and also the
transmission program global is a LNS
will will manage all is related to the
termination of the lower one protocol
OLMS is osted in victory comes data
center
then we have a solution built on GCP in
order to processing message from the RNs
there is a front-end develop in PHP and
in react and the backend mainly
developed in go the architecture of the
backend is based on different
microservices from SH processing once a
survey once the services emerge build
Jaster in the Google Cloud registry then
they are deploy in containers
orchestrated by kubernetes so that I can
be using three different way by the
customer directly on those pot platform
or with REST API or easier with IOT IOT
connector why we why herbs in use bill
or solution on GCP there is five
different reason the first one is for
maximum ease of use and day-to-day
operation for our team for all IT team
the next point is to under its and be
stored during the keynotes its
GKN able to avoid the locking and said
very important for our genius to have
that the next one is to to use and to
use managed service and also have the
services scalable in function of our
need and the device presence of on our
network sorry
customer compatibility we were
previously on the another cloud and a
big customer in France Kafue that we
work with them this I did wanted that we
change the cloud because they are what
they are not big fan of of the previous
cloud and the last one is the last ones
it's the fact that with GCP we have the
best community services
so you know everything about Laura and a
genius so you are expert in the insert
technology so we will go into another
part of the of the talk about asset
tracking and before I talk to you about
a specific use case of mobility I will
show you a short video and another
korean case to get a quick overview of
the value chain on the different issues
that might exist on this topic it's in
french motor is subtitle
but the greater Paris project 200
kilometers of tunnels will be dug by
2030 this will generate 43 million tons
of excavated materials that will need
removing to control its environmental
impact and traceability associated acaba
he invented a platform for its
contractors since June 2016
Wakaba publique has been working on a
complementary system to make in putting
on the interface easier and guaranteeing
traceability thanks to the Geo
localization of its trucks the position
only cameo give actually tell the
combined silica target is youma they
click any one position capture solar
then you can you know flash Eric
insulator as free capital dispose
inclusive FC after come the Kathmandu
Valley noxious for the capture is a
congressman Issa mr. with the tablet
it's possible to specify the type of
materials the site where it's unloaded
and its tonnage the truck can then hit
the road
I hope they always kept their activity
and I said oh I'm at yeah I kept to
activate detect any movement with [ __ ]
you can even to continued the Clement
was moving along Regina Lasko always a
good clinical with Laura
the French network for connected objects
weak Tilikum passes on all this
information the control panel then tells
you where and when unloading took place
the vacuous condition see obviously the
device was just occasionally be visibly
at whatever Jack tamale Hodges records
when he came he didn't pull you on kiss
Monica Ocampo Josh a donor history
what pies in candy guru cameo additional
walk for site managers the solution has
numerous advantages Yamaha Indonesia
University no pitocin law in best to
risk there are the city palace errata
we talked it on player Morris's ich they
do nish tomorrow solidification
the provide the dear dudes activity not
gonna wreck include activities the
online applications he supplies la
Chrissy's actually posting the
Pacifica's expected on site in June 2017
UB saw could become the most reliable
way to meet the needs of the society
become happy
[Music]
so let's talk about tracking and IOT we
Virginia's first to an interesting
number that we have seen among all a IOT
projection in of genius vii more than
75% are for project have Jacques
geolocation needs obviously they are not
identical it can be tracking on
equipment with a great accuracy with
intensive sending of messages because
the object is in movements and the
customer wants to know the position
every 10 minutes it can be just a van
appreciate approximate position to know
if my object is still in the area
because my object is supposed to be
static this number is directly linked to
the advantage of a flora and the fact
that the battery can be very long the
message can be sent on the great range
the low cost and the fact that it's a
flexible approach the lower technology
can be applied you know to almost every
sector so let's go in detail of a
customer problem so the customer case
that I will detail you concern one of
the European automotive leader this
project concern essential equipment for
the supply chain in order to to chip the
manufactured product it's called
packaging so to give a bit of context
the company has designed a factory in
Europe in England in France or either in
Spain and each working together on
different component of the car the
packaging there is a lot of packaging in
a large number of packaging using its
represent million of units and thousand
of different type and this equipment I
use between the plant but also with the
supplier so is it's a problem because
it's a problem because packaging is very
important for the business to have a
good of
a good efficient flow of pack of goods
throughout the supply chain so without
that it lead to description and money
waste because of extra cost linked to
the to the problem of supply chain so as
I say as I previously said there is a
lot of facets it represent of a huge
amount of but a single equipment does
not justify an every envis to track them
so that's why they're using Laura and
the aim of this project was to track
packaging in order to improve the
efficiency of the management of this
equipment to to answer to the customer
problematic we have did we have
identified three main component the
coverage our objective our lower one
coverage hood sides of French territory
the location thanks to Laura we have a
different type of location with
different level of accuracy and
different properties and finally the
visualization I was a customer going to
see the data how is going to be able to
exploit it and what's a business
indicator of wildon indeed so let's go
in detail of each of them so regarding
the coverage of the different sites
outside France there is two option
available the first concern roaming with
other European player since Laura is
present globally some foreign operator
of also deploy or lower one network in
the country we have already signed some
agreement roaming agreement with some of
the player like such as Switzerland
Belgium Germany but many others and so
roaming is very interesting because it's
a it's possible to route to respond and
answer to this kind of problematic at
the European level or even worldwide
level the Contra part of warming it's
the fact that we depend on the
of deployment of this partner the second
option is coverage on demand it's the
name of a generous offer and basically
just to install a gateway in the planned
customer sites the Gateway is already
connected to a lot LNS so the message
it's directly link sense to own an LMS
it's quickly and easy to install the the
problem with this solution that we we
have the location location of a set in
Omni on the site where the Gateway is
installed as previously says that there
is different type of location with Laura
Zera there are several several ways to
locate your equipment it with the
advantages among the four possibility we
will observe different level of accuracy
from few meters 200 meters different
conception battery consumption different
using outdoor or indoor the choice of
the client can be a combination of
several several of them with this white
choice we are able to respond to
different scenario and provides the
answer bed suit to customer use case one
of them is very interesting is tdos the
second one cos or time difference of
arrival and it's based on the three
regulation of messages with at least
three gateways so t0 is very into is
really interesting because without GPS
it's a lot or precise accuracy and in
Dawn's area with a long battery life so
this this solution is the best cost
accuracy ratio and finally the last
point I was a customer will will see the
data so it's also a platform spot
which is possible to visualize and have
a dedicated feature to geo-tracking
so on the on the screen there is a soil
map then we can check the position of
every assets with a color code to give
us an information about the status of
the equipment if there is a problem or
technical area or some stuff like that
it's also possible to visualize path of
the of the device on different time
interval we also can configure area area
of interest in order to motive to
monitoring a specific geographical area
such be alert if there is a device enter
would go out this this area and finally
the last point with with this feature is
the fact that all the position are
record and it's available to user to to
have a various treatment if the case of
of the European automotive leader
they're using the spot platform at the
beginning and to have a very important
and business metrics they build a
personal dashboard based on this
information and based on our API and
just quickly to sum up the benefit of
the solution for the customer so it with
with sports and Laura it could locate
any single equipment at any location the
data were available to share with any
system like that he can build his own
dashboard and create East Cathy I and
the last point is there is an
interesting payback of roughly one years
so to conclude Laura and project in IOT
it's it's working and it's already in
production
[Music]